OK, so today i want to talk about a
little bit what it's like growing up
poor in London
not at all to undermine
what it's like growing up in any other
parts of the country or the world for
that matter because
i'm sure there's a lot of problems
everywhere you go but i'm
talking about personal experience of what
it was like growing up in London
The specific thing that is different
about growing up poor
in London is that if you're poor in
London you're poor but you're
surrounded by Wealth
not just like the big skyscrapers
in the city
but there are a lot of people that
have quite a lot of money right
& theres a lot of people who earn
quite a lot of money
and i think a big thing that made it
different for me you know
as you know i got into a
grammar school out in Ilford
and then i went to a school where
most of the people were from sort of
comfortable, relatively well-off families
when i went to their houses
they had like massive houses
like at my primary school
it was like it was a lot of sort of
Pakistani immigrants you know like fresh
over and a lot of them
their houses obviously their cultural
background was different to mine
but their financial situation was quite
similar you know you entered a house it
was like a crowded house
a lot of people like squeezed into
a small house you know
and that was similar to like my situation
but then when i went to the
grammar school
you know
people had their own big bedrooms with a
big bed and a big desk and it was like
everything was like nicely
done and like they had like hallways you
know in the house a hallway
i remember i went to this one guy's
i remember i went to this one guy'S
house Rory Sheen's house
and um the stairway like split
he had to stay with that split and i
remember thinking like this guy's got a
stairway that splits
you know i mean and like i was sharing
this tiny little bedroom
with a little bunk bed with my brother
you know tiny tiny room like right next
to the railway
and um if you're poor but everyone
around you is poor
i'm not saying that's easy but it's a
it's harder in the sense when you're
poor and there's so many people around
you who are rich
because it puts a difference between you
and i remember like non-uniform day on
uniform day right i didn't have nothing
to wear you know what i mean everyone
else are like
people not some people wearing all these
designer clothes i didn't have nothing
to wear and eventually i just started i
started wearing school uniform on
non-uniform day you know
because i didn't have nothing to wear
*I had no idea thats why...*
yeah because it's just like
i'm not going to play this game
like it's setup against me
but i think
yeah when you see
all that wealth around you what that
and your poor
what that does to you is first of all
it makes you want it it makes you want
it so badly
i think like it's difficult to be poor
but when you're surrounded by people
who have things you don't have
you know what i mean
um you know like i remember
when we all turned like
16/17 & everyone else was getting
driving lessons and they got cars
and i couldn't get one
you know what i mean
what that highlights to you is
also how unfair it is
because like you'll probably remember i
started doing a paper at 13
364 days a year i was waking up every
364 days a year i was waking up everY
single day, 6:45
going out to deliver papers
and no one else was doing that in our
and no one else was doing that
in our school and i was the
poorest kid in school
you know i mean it's like um so i'm the
only one who's actually working
i'm working every single day of the year
except for christmas day and
everyone else has got more money than me
and when time comes around for like
who's going to get a car
everyone gets a car except me you know
everyone gets a car except me
you know what i mean and then like
people judge you, like i remember one
time i was hanging out with some
girls and they was like "oh have you seen
Raj's new car
he must be doing really well"
& i was thinking like we're 17
what do you think he's doing
you know what i mean? but like
people judge you
on your financial position
when you're a teenager
they do and it's stupid but they do
and people know that you're poor
when you're 15/16
it can't possibly be your fault that
you're poor you know what i mean
i was doing everything i could
i was working a paper round and i was 15.
what else could i do? you know what i mean?
waking up 6:45 every day for £12 a week
you know and i have to save
up every every week
but i think that's the specific thing
about growing up poor in london
because you're surrounded by so much
wealth you want it so badly
and i think that's nowadays with the
growth of things like
instagram and facebook where
it's become like quite fashionable for
people to really sort of casually
display
the things that they have like holidays
or like cars or like watches or clothes
you know in a sense i thought
we were lucky that we
grew up a little bit before that era
where it wasn't so easy to
display your wealth but now
i think kids are probably on
instagram from like i don't know
10 or 11 or maybe younger
and then they're gonna see all of these
displays of how much wealth and things
other people have
and it's always displayed beautifully on
instagram that's only gonna make it
worse right kids are gonna see that kids
from poor backgrounds
they're going to see it
and it makes you want it
you see it every day
you see it in your life you see it on
instagram you see it in advertisement
you see it in the movie you see it on the tv
you see in the movie you see on the tv
and if you're from a poor background you
know you can't have it
and the other people
in London you'll be surrounded by
people who can have it
and you can't have it and um
if you hit kids with that every single
day every single day every single day
you can't be surprised when they get
addicted to online training
or maybe they turn to crime or they
start selling drugs you know what i mean
or they start getting involved in things
like fraud you know what i mean
because a big
factor which i think is really important
is um
back one generation ago like we're here
in Ilford it's got a massive indian
community massive Pakistani community
a lot of our friends they came over from
India, Pakistan, East Africa
one generation, two generations ago
with nothing, with not a penny to their name
and they worked and they worked and
they worked and they saved and they saved
and they saved and a lot of those families
are pretty wealthy now you know
they've got multiple properties
they're really comfortable, they've got a nice
quality/standard of living
so they lived in an era where
even if you grew up in London and saw
this wealth around you
It was true that if you're willing
to pull your socks up
and work really hard you could get it
you could get it so as long as you
you know maybe you needed to make a lot
of sacrifices and you know you know
very well a lot of our parents
and our friends parents
did make massive sacrifices
if you are willing to make your
sacrifice you can get those things but
the problem is now
increasingly for young people that's not
true so then you're putting young people
you know especially young men who are
very often judged
really strictly on their financial
success you're putting them in a
situation where they've got nothing
they're surrounded by people
who've got things they can't have
they're seeing it displayed to them on
instagram every single day
they're seeing it on the tv, in the movies
on advertisements every single day
movies on advertisements every single day
but no matter how hard they work
no matter what they do
they can never get that stuff
like what is that, right?
that is the recipe for a mental health
disaster for young men - that's what it is
if you create a situation where
you create a desperate urgent need
and you surround someone with other
people who have a thing
and you tell them they can't have it and
you don't give them any legitimate route
to getting that thing
you cannot be surprised when these
people turn to crime and these people
turn to dangerous means of getting it
like online trading and stuff like this um
and that's what I've seen in my opinion
a massive increase in
online trading and gambling
gambling addictions because
we've created a generation of young men
who have had
wealth and financial success
shoved down their throats for their whole
childhood and have no legitimate means
of getting those things
and yeah that i think
that's what happened
and yeah what i was saying before was
like i think another thing which really
drives financial anxiety is when
things change in the economy very
things change in the economy very quickly
so like if you have a society which is
very unequal
but things are not moving quickly then i
think poor people will
just accept we're poor like yeah
it's not good it's s*** we're poor but
we have a community of poor people and
we're all the same i'm all equal but
what we've done in our society is we've
shuffled the deck really really quickly
so for our parents generation like I've
said it was true
that a lot of them were poor but as long
as they worked hard they could become
relatively rich
but for our generation that's not true
so what that means is
we've moved very quickly from a world
where
everybody had that basic ability
to get themselves financially secure to
one where whether you can be financially
secure or not
is actually out of your control and it
depends on what your parents and your
grandparents did
so what that means is then we bear that
responsibility of
well that means if i don't make it my
kids are screwed
you know what i mean because we lived in
a world where
even if you were poor you could become
rich so that means like all i need to do
is make sure that my kids are healthy
and happy and then they can make it for
themselves but now we've moved into a
world where
if you can't give your kids a big
inheritance
then they'll probably never get a house
so what that means is it's not enough
for me to be a good father it's not enough for
me to give my *kids* a stable happy childhood
i need to make money otherwise they will
not be financially secure
so then suddenly
people are in a situation where it's not
just their necks on the line you know
it's not just a case of can i get a nice
holiday or not
you know it's not a case of can i get a
nice car it's literally a case of if you
don't make it
your kids will not be financially secure
and that's what happens when you create
an economy
where only kids from rich families can
buy houses
that means i need to be rich or my kids
will be poor
so suddenly there's so much more
pressure on individuals
because you
need to build that money in order for
your kids to have a chance
and that's what happens when you create
a society where rich families always stay rich
and poor families always stay poor
but we're going to decide now which
families are going to be in the rich and
which families are gonna be in the poor
so then it's like oh my god i need to
work really hard really quickly i need
to make that cut
because i'm seeing people
you know like your parents & my parents
come from similar financial backgrounds
but now they're in very different
financial places right and that's affecting
our positions and it's going to be the
same for our kids so suddenly there's
all this additional pressure like if i
don't hustle if i don't work hard then
that's going to ruin my future chances
of my kids and um
yeah honestly i think it's the situation
it's creating it's it's
it's a mental health disaster and it's
going to lead to increases in
kids looking into crime
kids getting into gambling
incidences of fraud because if you
create a situation where
you create a desperation for people to
make money
but you don't create a legitimate means
for them to make money
it's inevitable that they will look to
do it in other ways
is it inevitable i think...
at the moment these guys are profiting
from a crisis
that is going to keep our economy in the
stump for 50 years
there is one other thing they can do
with that mass amount of income
they can buy your mom's house